president from struggles to deal with
the fallout from the alleged Saudi
murder of a dissident president Trump
battles it out with stormy Daniels in
the great battle of our time and we're
going to talk about some fundamental
conservative principles today I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
stop the hammering I only say that
because if you can't actually hear that
through my microphone there's
legitimately hammering going on on the
floor beneath us as we build out our new
lair our fantastic new studios which
will be unveiled sometime in the future
just like the Shapiro store may take
longer to materialize then I say it will
but eventually it will arrive there is
news to get to today and philosophy to
get you today many many things to talk
about but first let us talk about the
upcoming election if you look at the
rhetoric from the leftist news outlets
on the heels of Brett Cavanaugh's
confirmation they are trying to solidify
the left for the midterms it is going to
be a battle for the house right now
chances are Democrats win the house here
is what's at stake if the Democrats do
take the house the positive policies
Republicans have enacted over the past
few years everything to help the economy
regulatory reform tax cuts judicial
appointments withdrawal from the Iran
deal all of it could be stymied if the
Dems take control of either house and
when they start to obstruct that might
have an effect on the dollar on stocks
on other unknowns that could impact your
savings so what is your plan can you
afford another hit to your retirement
like last downturn when the S&P dropped
50% well hedge against inflation hedge
against uncertainty and instability with
some precious metals doesn't mean take
all your money and put it in gold but
you should have some of your money in
precious metals gold is a safe haven
against uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified and yours should be as well
the company I trust for precious metal
purchases is Birch gold group and right
now thanks to a little-known IRS tax law
you can even move your IRA or eligible
401k into an IRA backed by physical gold
and silver perfect for folks who want to
protect those hard-earned retirement
savings from future geopolitical
uncertainty when the bottom falls out of
everything else gold tends to safeguard
savings right now go check out Birch
gold at birchgold.com /ban that's
birchgold.com /ban contact Birch gold
group now and you can request a free
information kit on physical precious
metals it's a 16 page kit showing how
gold and silver can protect your savings
go check it out right now
birchgold.com /ban they're the folks I
trust for investments in precious metals
birchgold.com /ban alright so we begin
today with the President of the United
States suggesting that if the Democrats
win the house it's not his fault that's
not a big shock I mean you wouldn't
expect President Trump he's not really a
the buck stops here guy
that's not his MO D'Amato he turns
to operate more in the buck stops
wherever I'm not and therefore if the
Republicans were to lose the house it
has nothing to do with President Trump
now let's be real about this with a
soaring economy the Republicans should
be doing better in polling than they are
Democrats are highly motivated to get
out and vote partially because of
President Trump do I think it's extra
because of Trump not really believe it
or not I think that Democrats are
motivated to vote because the Republican
is in the White House and it would be
the same thing if it had been Jeb Bush I
think they would have been motivated to
vote midterm elections are really bad
for sitting presidents and this election
cycle is no different if it turns into a
raucous blowout if it turns into
Democrats winning 4050 seats then you
might start talking about the impact
President Trump has had obviously
president Trump has a unique gift for
both getting the worst out of his
opponents and the worst out of himself
from time to time and when I say from
time to time I mean on a not infrequent
basis which is why we're now talking
about stormy Daniels mushrooms Mario
Kart and horse faces well get to all of
that in just a second but President
Trump said yesterday that if the
Republicans do indeed lose the house
it's not on him if they don't go out and
vote then they have themselves to blame
because they'll lose wealth tremendous
amount I built up eleven point seven
trillion dollars and wealthy report on
it okay so you know when he suggests
that it's not his fault because we have
you know a great economy he's right that
we do have a terrific economy right now
there's a study out today and it shows
that the United States is now number one
number one in competitiveness for the
first time in 2008 after May the second
highest overall gained from the previous
year's ranking from the World Economic
Forum according to Ryan's Vedra over at
Daily wire the top five countries where
the US Singapore Germany Switzerland and
Japan all of which saw their scores
increase in 2017 according to The Wall
Street Journal economic recovery is well
underway with the global economy
projected to grow almost 4% in 2018 and
2019 the report stated adding that the
recovery remains vulnerable to a range
of risks and potential shocks as just a
way for economists to hedge their bets
their journal noted that the warning
cited quote a brewing trade war between
the US and China as a possible hindrance
to growth that could potentially derail
the recovery and deter investment the
report scores countries on how closely
they match up to the competitive ideal
the US scored an 86% out of a possible
100 America's vibrant
- entrepreneurial culture and its
dominance in producing a competitive
labor market and nimble financial system
are among the several factors that
contribute to making in the United
States his innovation ecosystem one of
the best in the world this prompted
President Trump to tweet out all of the
good economic news he tweeted out
incredible number just out over seven
million job openings astonishing it's
all working stock market up big on
tremendous potential of USA also strong
profits we are number one in the world
by far which is true he says that we now
have eight times more new manufacturing
jobs than we did under President Obama
also true the fact is that the economy
has been going gangbusters under
President Trump and a large part of that
is not only the regulatory reform and
the tax cuts but a feeling of
consistency and certainty in economics
see it's very important to have a level
of consistency and certainty if you are
running a business if you're living in
the state of California where we are and
you run a business one of the problems
is you are not sure what insane
regulation is going to come down the
pike at any given moment and on a
federal level if you don't know what
crazy regulation is gonna come down the
pike in any given moment you're more
likely to hold out your money you're
more likely to say you know what I'm
gonna leave that money in the bank I'm
not going to invest in a new employee I
may have to fire I'm not going to invest
in new infrastructure that may have to
be unmei have to go unused instead I'm
just gonna hold this money out and I'm
gonna wait for a better economic time
president Trump and Republican Congress
mean that there is a level of solidity
and Americans perceptions of which way
the economy is going to move namely in
the direction of businesses having more
freedom to pursue the the causes that
they wish to pursue but now President
Trump is is signaling that the great
danger to this is the Federal Reserve
the Federal Reserve has been tightening
interest rates the reason they're
tightening interest rates is because
they don't want a bubble they don't want
a lot of folks taking out cheap credit
from the Federal Reserve banks lending
out at cheap rates and then all of those
assets being overvalued and then the
economy collapsing again like it did in
2007-2008 so the Federal Reserve
actually isn't doing the worst thing the
fact the government the fact that the
economy continues to grow at
extraordinary rates with the Federal
Reserve tightening credit is actually
quite a good thing but here as president
Trump suggesting that the economy might
be a little bit more fragile than we
think it is by going after the Federal
Reserve thread is the Fed
because the Fed is raising rates too
fast and it's independent so I don't
speak to him but I'm not happy with what
he's doing
because it's going too fast because you
looked at the last inflation numbers
they're very low okay and it's in it's
you know debatable as to whether the Fed
should even exist but if the Fed is
going to exist and raising interest
rates in a time of economic boom is not
the world's worst idea however there is
a problem we do have this booming
economy right 7 million unfilled jobs
it's an amazing statistic for all the
talk about the hollowing out of the
American middle class and the people who
are living in despair in small-town
communities 7 million unfilled jobs is a
lot of unfilled jobs that is a lot of
unfilled jobs and we are a country
originally of pioneers and entrepreneurs
people who are willing to venture out of
the spaces from which they were born in
order to find new economic opportunities
and new jobs the problem is that an
economy that's booming like this but
that also may require you to add new
skills and move out of your hometown
it's deeply at odds with some president
Trump's campaign promises it's deeply at
odds with a certain perception of the
economy that's pushed by the so called
populist right now when I talk about
populist right I'm talking about folks
who I think say a lot of true things and
a lot of a lot of subjects but not on
this particular subject they and in this
in this particular camp I count a bunch
of folks who have made big names for
themselves based on the idea that
America's economy is bound to fail that
there's too much income inequalities
from the right these are people
supposedly from the right claiming
there's too much income inequality the
manufacturing jobs are dying that small
towns are dying and therefore the
government has to step in and regulate
we need tariffs we need regulations we
need redistributions we need heavier
unionization and this comes from a value
system that doesn't actually see the
morality in the free markets per se now
listen there's nothing that is
necessarily moral and how people use
free markets but the basis of a free
market system private property ownership
and control of your own labor that is a
deep moral good there's something moral
about free markets that is not moral
about restricted markets that can only
hold true when there's no exploitation
that can only hold true
when the government prevents forced use
of labor for example but when the
government steps in and starts trumping
on free-market principles on individual
property rights an individual use of
labor then you get into trouble and the
problem is that there is a widespread
perception among a lot of people on the
populace right that America's economy
even when it's going great guns is still
unfair this is where the trumpian right
meets the Bernie Sanders left Tucker
Carlson has a new book out called ship
of fools we're gonna have Tucker on the
Sunday special sometime in the near
future when Tucker is sort of an
economic economic populist very talented
guy obviously and Tucker's economic
populism borders on sort of a Bernie
Sanders perspective on how the economy
ought to work he talks a lot in his book
about this sort of suffering middle
class that was left behind and one of
the things he says in the book is that I
was reading it last night and it's
really well written it's again Tucker's
a deeply talented guy one of the things
that it says is it says that well the
rich have gotten richer in the United
States the poor have gotten poorer now
he acknowledges that the poor getting
poorer in the United States is not
actually a thing that's happening that
the poor in the United States are still
extraordinarily rich by any sort of
global standard
they are richer than they were in 1979
by any standard they have better stuff
but that's not enough because he says
that there's still Envy between the rich
and the poor and as long as that exists
the government has to step in to help
prevent that Envy from overtaking the
political system that's a perspective
that probably Bernie Sanders supporters
hold and you saw some of this during the
election cycle when President Trump was
trying to appeal to Bernie Sanders
supporters with the same sort of
language the free markets were flawed
that globalization was a bad thing this
is the stands and by the way for free
markets the the dirty word that people
use instead of free markets these days
is globalization
now there are significant problems with
globalization on the local level in
certain areas so for example you're
getting out competed by a business in
China and your business goes out of
business that hurts for you but
globalization is just another word for
free markets because if you were getting
out competed by a farm in California in
your in Ohio that wouldn't be
globalization that would just be the
free market at work there are moral
questions as to whether we should be
doing free-market stuff with
dictatorships like China but there's no
economic question that it is beneficial
economically to consumers in the United
States and to producers who use inputs
in the United States to have free
and yet by suggesting that capitalism
and free markets are not enough
suggesting that globalization is a bad
thing what we need is economic
nationalism or government intervention
president Trump is actually undercutting
the cause of his own economy which is
not based on anti-globalization it's
actually based deeply on a global free
market and on less regulation president
Trump's economic system is based on less
government intervention in the economy
but president Trump has been preaching
more economic intervention in the
economy by suggesting that the economy
is leaving people behind
well that's eternities a talking point
that can be used against him it's a
talking point that can be used against
him in elections and it's also a talking
point that is not particularly
conservative which I'm going to explain
in just one second but first let's talk
about what you do in case of natural
disaster so we've seen now a hurricane
hit in Florida two hurricanes this year
hit in Florida with pretty significant
consequences for a lot of folks you seen
hurricane hit in Houston we've seen
hurricanes hit in Puerto Rico we've seen
earthquakes we've seen tsunamis I mean
natural disasters are a time where you
look around the world and you say well
it wouldn't be good if I were actually
prepared for something like that that is
why you need to go check out my Patriot
supply right now you know hurricanes
natural disasters and things hit with
very little warning and that's why you
need to be prepared up front so go
secure an emergency food supply the
government says you should do it anyway
try trust my Patriot supply to do this
you should too you get a 2-week food kit
to get you started this week it's on
special for only 75 bucks when you go to
my special website prepare with Ben's
comm or call eight eight eight eight oh
three 14 13 that's eight eight eight
eight oh three 14 13 these food kits
include meals that last up to 25 years
in storage order now prepare yourself so
there are no surprises eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen or
prepare with Ben calm that's eight eight
eight eight oh three fourteen thirteen
or prepare with Ben calm again you need
to prep in case something bad should
happen it's always better be safe than
sorry
eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen or prepare with Ben
calm to get that two-week emergency food
supply and again you're not gonna have
to worry about it again because you'll
be prepped so go check it out right now
prepare with Ben calm okay so it's not
just Tucker I don't wanna pick on Tucker
they're a bunch of folks again who I
really admire intellectually I think
Tucker is one of them another person who
I admire intellectually is a guy named
Orrin Kass who has a book out that I've
recommended on the show called the ones
in future worker and in that book Oren
talks about this kind of new populist
economics
what he says is basically capitalism is
designed to provide you the cheapest
products and the best products at the
most available opportunity and there's
no question that this is what capitalism
is achieved this is what globalization
has achieved we live in times that would
astound any human being from even 50
years ago we live in a time economically
where legitimately you can have any
product on planet Earth delivered to you
within days made in 10 different
countries assembled in a factory
overseas shipped directly to your house
you only have to leave your house all
you do is push push a button and these
things arrive there's a very famous
economic essay called eyepencil all
about how no one on planet earth
actually knows how to make a pencil
beginning to end why because there's a
graphite factory and then there's a wood
factory and then there's a paint factory
there's a metal factory there's a rubber
factory all of those places have to
generate small pieces of the pencil and
then it is all assembled and then it is
brought to you for pennies that's the
magic of capitalism that's the magic of
globalization and free markets now when
people say globalization again because
people think that globalization means
that we are giving up control to people
who are outside America they don't
understand that globalization really
just means free markets we just had free
markets folks would be on board but
globalization is an easy way to - it's
kind of a left-liberal term for free
markets that's been used just like
trickle-down economics is a left-liberal
term that has been used instead of
supply-side economics
well Oren cast in his book he talks
about how capitalism is great at
generating all sorts of consumer goods
that capitalism is consumer focused
which obviously is true it's it's
consumed capitalism with making sure
that you can not only dispense with your
own labor at the price that you see fit
but also that you provide products and
services to somebody else that they want
what he says is that we may be living in
a time very soon where people can't find
fulfillment in consumerism instead they
find fulfilment in jobs they find
fulfillment in work now there's no
question that a guy making $20,000 a
year and working is probably happier
than a guy making $20,000 a year from
welfare and not working but the real
question is how much economic
wherewithal do you have to sacrifice how
much free market you have to sacrifice
to give that guy a job at $20,000 as
opposed to just redistributing and this
is
a fascinating kind of economic debate
that is breaking out I think it's
premature but it's fascinating I'll
explain in just one second so here is
the new debate on the right in economics
and it sort of crosses political
boundaries it's really quite interesting
on the one hand you have folks who say
globalization and redistribution what do
we do with the people who are left
behind who are working jobs that get
eliminated who can't change jobs who
don't want to leave their hometown now
the normal answer in the past was get up
get a new skill leap town right that was
the new that was the actual American
answer that's why America spans from
coast to coast and isn't just relegated
to the eastern seaboard because people
legitimately gave up plots of land in
New York and decided I'm gonna go out to
the middle of nowhere I'm gonna cross
territory where people want to kill me
and I'm gonna go out to the middle of
nowhere to set up a claim and then I'm
going to work on that claim by myself at
risk of death in order so that I can
make something more of myself right that
is the American ideal the pioneer the
cowboy is still the American ideal but
that sort of is gone by the wayside
because we now believe that everybody is
entitled to things where an entitlement
culture and so what's broken down is two
separate views of where the economy
should go from here view number one is
globalization and redistribution free
markets everywhere
and if people are left behind then we
have a basic income ready universal
basic income or we have a social welfare
net a safety net and that's how we pick
up for the folks who get left behind
right those people we just give them
money basically so globalization raises
everybody's living standard and then
everybody who's left behind a little bit
we give them a little bit of extra money
to make them feel better and so that
they can live better that is model
number one and a lot of folks in sort of
the Trump camp say that's not right and
the Bernie camp say that's not right
they say instead what we really need is
a new model of how to think and the
model of how to think is about jobs how
do we provide jobs from people because
jobs provide meaning and if you don't
have a job you have less meaning so what
if we just restricted the free market
itself what if we put barriers on the
free market now to Oren's credit Orrin
Kass he doesn't really recommend tons of
restrictions on the free market he talks
about different ways that we could shape
public policy in order to make the
markets free or actually relieve
regulations to make it easier to
generate jobs but President Trump has
suggested restrictions on the free
market he's he has suggest
said restrictions on global trade for
example and there's a real push by some
on the trumpian populist right to
restore union power even though it is
Americans voluntarily moving out of
private unions not companies breaking
unions that is led to the death of
unions in the United States
so that's model number two is you
restrict the free market economy in
order so that everybody has a job and
that again is more of a left-leaning
version so it's kind of fascinating
because you have liberals who are for
globalization and redistribution and you
have conservatives or for globalization
and redistribution and you have liberals
who are for workers and not free markets
and you have conservatives who are for
workers and not free markets now the
actual answer to this problem is look at
what free markets do look at what free
markets do and if President Trump were
really a free-market minded guy that's
what he would be saying right now he
knew all he would do is just pointed at
his economy he was saying you know
you're all worried about technological
developments you're all worried about
automated cars and trucks and all the
rest of this well guess what there's no
question that that capitalism has a
process of creative destruction attached
to it at Joseph Schumpeter the famous
economist coined this term creative
destruction that every time a new
industry is created old industries are
destroyed the car industry destroyed the
horse and buggy industry wheelwrights
went out of business there were
literally people whose job it was to
make wooden wheels and they went out of
business when cars came around but guess
what that created new jobs in the car
industry and new jobs in making parts
for those cars in other words certain
jobs get destroyed so that we can all
live a better lifestyle and people have
to learn to adapt and adjust and that's
the history of humanity forget
capitalism the history of humankind is
adapting and adjusting to the
environment around you this idea that we
can't adapt and adjust to new
technologies seems to me completely
wrongheaded all of the talk about how
all of these jobs are simply going to
disappear thanks to technology and how
we have to restore manufacturing jobs by
restricting the free market it's a big
mistake the reason that we live the most
prosperous life's any human beings have
ever lived in the history of time is
because of these free markets all of the
talk we talked about this last week all
of the talk about how wages are the same
between 1979 and 2018 neglects the fact
that you can get
stop for one third the price you could
in 1979 if I'm making the same amount of
money in 1979 as I am now but now my
money goes three times further I'm
making three times when I was making in
1979 effectively speaking because the
value of money is what you can get for
the money so I think that this debate is
not only premature I think it's
wrongheaded and I think it's gonna lead
to bad public policy I think this debate
is going to lead to restrictions
regulations crackdowns on free markets
all in the name of an unknowable evil
that has yet to manifest itself there's
under 4% unemployment in the United
States right now it's about 4%
unemployment that's basically full
employment there's 7 million unfilled
jobs before we destroy a system that
creates this sort of prosperity might
want to think twice
I don't know thanks guys ok meanwhile
when the Trump administration is
undergoing some severe difficulty with
regard to foreign policy specifically
thanks to Mohammed bin Sultan the Saudi
Crown Prince allegedly deploying a
security team to Istanbul in Turkey and
they murdered a Saudi dissident we will
get to that in just one second first
speaking of death let's talk about life
insurance so you never know when you're
going to be called to a Saudi consulate
in Istanbul woman chopped up and
liquefied that's why you need life
insurance and probably that's not the
way that you'll go but at some point you
will go and when you do then you will
probably need life insurance because the
fact is that your family's gonna need
money your income means something and
beyond that just keep your family
provided for guys well this is where
policy genius comes in they compare
quotes from the top life insurance
companies and they find the best policy
for you it takes just two minutes to get
a quote and if you don't know the first
thing about insurance they've got all
the tools to get you up to speed
learn the difference between term and
whole life insurance calculate how much
coverage you need be sure you're making
the right decision in fact over 4
million people have used policy genius
to shop for insurance policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
home insurance auto insurance if you
care about it they can cover it so
whether you know a lot about life
insurance you don't know anything at all
I'll go to policy genius.com and start
your search in two minutes you can
compare quotes make an informed decision
for you and your loved ones again
there's no excuse for you not to have
life insurance it's just a responsible
thing to do policy genius is the easy
way to compare and buy life insurance
policy genius.com
go check them out right now ok so as we
say
the President of the United States is in
hot water specifically because the Saudi
government has basically put him in a
very rough position here's the rough
position they put him in Mohammed bin
Sultan was considered the new reformer
in Saudi Arabia and indeed Mohammed bin
Sultan looked as though he was a guy
who's going to help lead this
anti-iranian coalition that continues to
be his value all of the talk about the
Saudi regime modernizing and moving
toward liberalism like classical
liberalism and all of that was
overstated it isn't as well it is an
Islamic dictatorship in which people
still have their hands chopped off for
theft it is not exactly a modern country
but we are all very shocked and appalled
as we should be when Saudi operatives
decided they're going to murder a
dissident at a Saudi consulate in
Istanbul so here's the Wall Street
Journal with the latest reporting Saudi
operatives beat drugged killed and
dismembered a dissident Saudi
journalists in the presence of the
kingdom's top diplomat in Istanbul
Turkish officials said Tuesday as
Washington urged Riyadh to provide
answers president Trump cautioned that
Saudi Arabia should be considered
innocent until proven guilty his
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo on a
visit to the kingdom said Saudi leaders
had strongly denied involvement and were
conducting a serious credible
investigation but Turkey is now
suggesting that they have tape of the
entire thing happening at least an audio
tape the entire thing happening which
can't be very pleasant I mean that that
sort of audio would be is almost as hard
to listen to as Lady gaga
recording in an interview with The
Associated Press Tuesday mr. Trump
compared the allegations that Saudi
agents had killed mr. Takagi
to the accusations of sexual misconduct
against Supreme Court justice Brett
Kavanaugh this is where President Trump
gets himself in trouble okay this is not
particularly smart now here there are
several possible responses to the Saudi
situation
response number one this is really bad
we should put some sanctions on Saudi
Arabia at least temporarily until they
provide some sort of answers on all of
this and until they punish the people
responsible and until they reform their
conduct that's possibility number one
possibility number two is you say yes
this is really bad also every country in
that region is basically a garbage heap
or is run like a garbage heap right
there the countries themselves the
people are I'm sure wonderful in many of
these countries but the administration
of Turkey Iran Iraq certainly Syria
certainly not certainly Lebanon Jordan
like none of these administrations are
great Western democracies okay these are
all garbage administrations so well we
could say is yes this is really bad also
for geopolitical realist reasons like
Henry Kissinger we still need to work
with the Saudis to contain the Iranians
right that's possibility number two and
then there's possibility number three
which is Trump telling The Associated
Press quote here we go again with you
know you're guilty until proven innocent
we just went through that with justice
Cavanaugh and he was innocent all the
way as far as I'm concerned some where
justice Cavanaugh screams in silent
agony as he is compared to Saudi
dictators who murder people in
consulates and then liquefy their bodies
that is just it's like when Trump said
during the Cavanaugh hearings that he'd
been accused of things too and Cavanaugh
just must have been smacking himself on
the forehead
show him the Piccard style double
facepalm it just it makes yeah the
president because the president sees
things in black and white terms on every
score he says this sort of stuff but
equating Brett Kavanaugh where there was
no evidence other than the allegation
alone against him with the Saudis
murdering a human who has disappeared
and where there is apparently audio
evidence an audio recording shared with
both the US and Saudi Arabia comparing
that to Brett Kavanaugh Brett Kavanaugh
I can't be a happy camper right now come
the hell on I mean really apparently on
the recording a voice can be heard
inviting the Consul to leave the room
the voice of a man Turkish authorities
identified as Saudi forensic specialists
a la Alta Becky can be heard
recommending other people present listen
to some music while he dismembers mr.
Kershaw Aggies body according to the
according to the tape hisagi was not
interrogated and said he was beaten up
drugged and killed by Saudi operatives
had flown in from Riyadh apparently he
was dismembered while he was still alive
so things went real well over there
all of this again is deeply deeply ugly
of course that doesn't actually answer
the question as to what President Trump
should do however and this is where
president Trump's best claim is that
he's basically just a realist trying to
make deals as far as possible and while
he appreciates the human rights
violations are bad
he is not going to stay up nights
worrying about the Saudi government
committing human rights violations that
we all know they've been committing for
years on end I mean this is the same
Saudi administration that has been quite
friendly with radical Muslims for
decades on end the vast majority of the
of the Saudi high of the 9/11 hijackers
were Saudi so suffice it to say the
Saudi regime is not exactly a wonderful
wonderful regime but doesn't mean the
United States doesn't have interests
with regard to Saudi Arabia as an
example of president from saying this
sort of thing repeatedly he was asked
about Helsinki you remember he had that
meeting in Helsinki with Vladimir Putin
where he was very complimentary of Putin
it was not his finest hour
Trish Regan who has a brand-new show on
Fox Business which is well worth for
watching she pressed President Trump on
Helsinki here's what Trump had to say
with Putin they want me to go up and
have a boxing match with him on stage I
was nice to him
I was nice to him but what happened is
when I walked off the stage everyone
said oh no that was great
we're on the plane all of a sudden the
fake news starts saying old Trump wasn't
tough enough and let me tell you if I
was too tough they'd say Trump was too
tough I could have a very good
relationship with Russia having a good
relationship with Russia would be a good
thing not a bad thing okay so there was
there was that right and when he says
that about Russia he said the same sort
of thing about Kim jong-un right this is
how Trump acts with regard to bad
dictators he basically determines
whether he needs them or not and then he
tends to treat them nicely if he needs
them because this is how Trump is
personally with all the people he deals
with if he needs you he's very nice to
you if he doesn't need you then he calls
you a horse face and that's what
President Trump does and so when people
are confused that President Trump isn't
calling Muhammad bin Sultana horse face
that's because that's not how President
Trump operates that does not mean
however that what the left says about
Trump's relationship with Saudi Arabia
is true so Ben Rhodes who is just the
worst Ben Rhodes a former national
security adviser to President Trump he's
just awful he's just awful he was the
guy who lied to the American people
about the Iran deal he was the leader of
the Iranian regime outreach effort on
the part of the Obama administration
actual outreach effort to an evil
dictatorship the lead sponsor of terror
on planet Earth
attacking President Trump suggesting
Trump is somehow responsible for Saudi
Arabia acting like Saudi Arabia
journalists everywhere are less safe
and let's face it we have a president
who says journalists are the enemy of
the state so values like freedom of
speech and dissent suddenly are very
endangered around the world and that's a
trend line that I think is getting much
worse and into this vacuum of any
advocacy for democratic values
I think it's putting people at risk and
there's nobody else who's going to fill
that vacuum at the president United
States in the United States of America
is not doing that okay this is why Trump
supporters are not going to resonate to
anything media are saying these days the
media covered for an administration that
did outreach to actual terrorists for
years upon years upon years so when
Trump says listen I'm not gonna go crazy
over the Saudi thing most Americans are
basically going to say okay well alright
now is that the proper action now the
proper action is probably the sanctions
at the very least and insistence on some
sort of change in Saturday but we do
have leverage over the Saudis to pretend
we don't is foolish but you know
President Trump is much more of a
foreign policy realist than some of his
predecessors and as a foreign policy
realist I think that it is not fully
outside the bounds of propriety for him
to suggest that it's it's a little much
to abandon the Saudis in the middle of
an actual ongoing Middle Eastern crisis
between Sunni and Shia okay in just a
second I want to talk about the great
battle of our time which is not Saudi
Arabia versus Iran or even Republicans
versus Democrats it is president Trump
versus stormy Daniels we'll get to that
in just one second but first let's talk
about your wireless belt let's face it
you are now paying too much for wireless
okay you are the big and big wireless
provider stands for a lot of things big
contracts big bills big fees agency has
a new 800 million dollar administrative
fee increase big Wireless doesn't want
you to know is that there is a way for
you to cut down your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month which is where mint Mobile
comes in they're the game-changing
company that's taken everything wrong
with big wireless and they have made it
right you can save like a thousand bucks
a year with mint mobile if you're paying
15 bucks a month without sacrificing
quality service because their coverage
is excellent mint Mobile makes it so
easy to cut your wireless bill down to
15 bucks a month you can use your own
phone with any mint mobile plan you can
keep your old number along with all your
existing contacts choose between 2 5 or
10 gigabyte 4G LTE plans there's no more
paying for unlimited data you're never
going to use this is where they've
understood the issue you're buying
unlimited data you don't you
unlimited data but you're getting
charged from limited data instead you're
choosing your plan and this helps you
charge pay pay less if you're not 100%
satisfied mint mobile has you covered
with their seven day money-back
guarantee so go check it out right now
to get your new wireless plan for just
fifteen bucks a month plus free shipping
on your new mint Mobile SIM card go to
mint mobile comm slash band that's em
int mobile comm slash Ben again cut that
Wireless bill to fifteen bucks a month
get free shipping on your mobile SIM
card
@m int mobile comm slash Ben that's mint
mobile comm slash Ben go check it out
okay so in just a second well gets a
Trump versus stormy the great battle of
our time but first you're gonna have to
go subscribe so for $9.99 a month you
get a subscription to daily wire when
you do you get all of the wondrous
benefits of being a daily wire
subscriber you get to feel in the
cockles of your heart that you are a
better human being plus you also get the
rest of my show life Clavin show live
Michael Knowles is terrible show lie to
get all of those things and with the
annual subscription $99 here you get
this the very greatest in beverage
vessels the leftist here's hot or cold
tumbler plus we also have all sorts of
other goodies today at 7 p.m. Eastern 4
p.m. Pacific we have our next episode of
daily wire backstage you want to ask
questions to God King Jeremy boring or
me or Clavin or Noel's or Alesha Krauss
well all you have to do is be a
subscriber and just ask those questions
we will answer them for you that's
happening today
at 4 p.m. my god I'm doing extra work
for you people the least you can do is
subscribe plus that helps us bring you
the sunday specials with people like
Andrew Clavin right I mean like here's
drew hi I'm Andrew Clavin this Sunday
I'm going to be on the Ben Shapiro show
Sunday special we're gonna talk about
another Kingdom my new podcast god man
life literature just about everything ok
so that is going to be awesome that's
our Sunday special next week it really
was a lot of fun yeah it's gonna be a
blast go check it out right now
subscribe also when you subscribe to
make sure the people like mathis get
paid my Mathis has been out of the room
for four months because Malthus has been
elevated you know over at this company
we've reward merit and non merit but we
also reward merit so Mathis has been out
of the room for months and that's
because you guys have something done
such a great job of paying us that we
are able
to elevate mathas pay which allows him
to treat his pompadour the way it ought
to be treated it allows him to quaff
that hair each and every morning to puff
it up like Elvis and to come in here and
really just style it out now the bad
news is that our normal producer Sonia
has pneumonia the good news is that
Mathis is here and I can tell because
he's three inches taller from Sonia just
because of his hair in any case you
should subscribe to make sure that
Mathis keeps getting paid and to make
sure that we can pay Sonya's medical
bills go check all of that at Daley
we're calm we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
mathis you knew you weren't going to get
off that easy dude he's been in here for
several days and he didn't get smacked
yet so that was just a requirement of
the job in any case the other big story
on everybody's radar today is a story
about tiny and her space the great
romance of our time so president Trump
leaded off yesterday you'll recall when
he decided that he was very very happy
the stormy Daniels had had been forced
to pay attorneys fees in the state of
Texas on a ridiculous defamation lawsuit
that she filed against him and he
tweeted out yesterday now I can go after
her space and her third-rate lawyer in
the great state of Texas she would
confirm the letter she signed she knows
nothing about me a total con and
everybody went nuts because he called
her horse face now there was a theory
online that he we know President Trump
is just bad at spelling so there was a
theory online that he didn't mean to
ride horse face he meant ride horse face
and you know unkind but fact-check harsh
but true in any case she does not you
know it is not good policy for the
President of the United States to be
doing any of those things let alone to
be saying that a woman he wants shagged
is a horse face it's a weird kind of
cellphone I write it look that woman
that I had sex with was so terrible and
ugly
hey okay that's that's a way to do it
ice but in any case storming Daniels
then replies in the typical classic
fashion for which she has known she's a
classy lady you know the kind of woman
who's featured in New York Magazine not
kidding
there's a full photo spread of stormy
Daniels is the new feminist leader
because she gets paid to have sex on
camera and then had sex with a married
man and then refused to shut up about it
after being paid a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars to shut up about it she
is a feminist heroine she is susan b
anthony my goodness so here's what she
tweeted she tweeted ladies and gentlemen
may I present your president in addition
to his um shortcomings he has
demonstrated his incompetence hatred of
women and lack of self-control on
Twitter again and perhaps a penchant for
bestiality game on tiny so this is weird
because now she's suggesting that she is
an actual horse right she says he has a
penchant for bestiality well the only
thing he said about horses was that
she's a horse face
but I gotta say I don't think is really
true I don't think the stormy Daniels is
a horse that she's by any objective
measure but in any case she says that he
has a penchant for bestiality which is
weird and then she says game on tiny so
the romance of tiny and horseface I mean
that's is this how it went back when
they first met or Trump woke up is it
you have a hose facing Schmidt
well here tiny and then they just
passionately made out is that basically
how that went well that wasn't the end
of the story the end of the story was
that Michael avenatti felt the need to
sign it to jump in so Michael avenatti
who I I adore Michael avenatti
I will be honest with you I have been
saying for four months now that I want
Michael avenatti not only to run for
president but to win the nomination for
the Democrats because I root for
entertainment value around here if we
are going to live this news cycle let's
live it I mean come on let's paint the
town red if we are going if we are going
to sin such that God has decided his
vengeance upon us shall be this news
cycle then let us revel in our sin so
Michael avenatti desperately wants to
run for president and in the last three
weeks has destroyed his own party's
credibility on Brett Kavanaugh lost a
lawsuit against President Trump now he
jumps in to the stormy Daniels Donald
Trump fight with a video so good that I
want to make it my permanent ringtone
here is Michael avenatti sounding off
for those who can't see Michael avenatti
you know this is this really high style
he has taken his phone turned it into
selfie mode and now he is filming
himself speaking very seriously into
camera about horse face here we go
it's a sad day in America when the
President of the United States calls a
woman a horse face Donald Trump should
be ashamed of himself I don't care if
you're on the right the left or the
center no man should call a woman a
horse base especially the President of
the United States I have two daughters I
think it's a disgrace
I don't care what your political
persuasion is you should condemn it as
well it's wrong it's so wrong it's the
wrong thing he paid his client off Trump
paid his client off $130,000 to shut up
about nailing her ten years before while
he was running for president but the
real problem is he called her a horse
face no one in this
country should be called the horseface
under amendment 87 of the Constitution
it should be illegal for anyone to be
called the horse face in a mirror I'm
sorry we need to play the beginning of
that again because the way he says horse
face like you can see his internal model
while going Michael avenatti you get his
internal monologue is don't laugh
Michael don't laugh when you say horse
face don't laugh dammit this is like his
fifth take this is fifth day because his
first floor it takes
he had breaking up play I have I dress
to my own when the President of the
United States calls a woman a horse face
oh I've laughed more in the last week
and a half thanks to this news cycle
than a horse race Oh dad love this idiot
oh it's the best it's the best but who
thought that was a great idea who's like
you know what I'm gonna jump into this
campaign because I'm gonna flip this cam
around the president should never call
anyone a horse face that's like the
ninth worst thing Trump did yesterday
like Trump said that Brett Kavanaugh was
equivalent to the Saudi government who
just killed a man
dismembered him and liquefied him and
Michael avenatti is deeply deeply
concerned about the horse face comments
woman a horse face had no president
should call I promise you by the way
that Bill Clinton called women far worse
than a horse face a way worse than a
horse face LBJ was not famous for his
for his gentility around women really
okay but we'll get to the media's
response to all of this because it was
just as hysterical and just as
over-the-top President Trump has a
unique gift he can make his enemies do
pretty much anything and they do and
they will so here is how the media
responded to all of this so media said
it is very very bad very very bad for
president Trump's who have called stormy
Daniels a horse face this is after weeks
of them reveling in her calling his
penis a Mario Kart character I mean
really they reveled in this is CNN
covered it endlessly she went on Jimmy
Kimmel and she actually picked out
mushrooms that she says his genitalia
looked like here is Don Lemon trying to
suggest how bad it is that that Donald
Trump would insult someone's physical
appearance by insulting president from
physical appearance so well done here
Don Lemon does he own a mirror as he he
keeps talking about people gaining
weight
and how people look has he Oh does he
own a mirror that doesn't have Vaseline
over it or or a cloth I mean all you
have to do is look in the mirror Donald
Trump is no prize and if I were him not
that I'm one either
I would keep my thoughts about other
people's looks to myself
you just didn't literally you just
didn't if I were him I would keep
people's he's ugly and he's fat and if I
were him I keep my thoughts about other
people's looks to myself I love that
this is a serious new segment on CNN
first of all Chris Cuomo and Don Lemon
in the same room like on the same split
screen the amount of brain wattage on
that screen right now if translated into
electricity might be able to lightly
toast a piece of bread my goodness but
that is yeah okay so yeah the American
people are definitely gonna take
seriously your admonitions about
name-calling when you say that the
president is a fat orange toad good job
guys
really really well done and you have
April Ryan who showed up on CNN to do
the same routine so April Ryan is urban
radio network reporter you'll recall
April Ryan from such hits as Kanye
West's wife's former sex tape lover
doesn't approve of Kanye West that
happened last week but April Ryan is now
the great adjudicator of class and
decency in the media very exciting stuff
from April Ryan what is he doing here
he's the president of United States
street its gutter if you only knew
there's a gutter it is no it's not going
it's there oh it's just so it was one
thing when she was quoting Ray J to
critique Kanye West it is another thing
when the President of the United States
goes after a woman who was insulting his
genitals on national television to the
chortling and laughter now listen none
of this is justification for Trump's
behavior but I think we already know who
President Trump is with regard to women
are we supposed to pretend I really like
is this our thing are we supposed to
pretend that the President of the United
States is some sort of gentle ad that
he's the king of Shimla in a horse face
yeah calling a man a horse face I
understand Michael avenatti calm
yourself it's just it's all of this is
just absurd it's just absurd
now the absurdity didn't stop there
President Trump continues to attack
Elizabeth Warren but not in the most
effective way how many times do I have
to tell you he needs to sign a check to
Elizabeth Warren for nine hundred and
seventy six dollars and 56 cents one
one-thousand twenty fourth of a million
dollars that's what he needs to do now
instead he's tweeting about her so he
tweeted Elizabeth Warren is being
hammered even by the left her false
claim of Indian heritage is only selling
to very low IQ individuals President
Trump on the attack again he's a hammer
in search of a nail sometimes he gets a
nail sometimes he gets a baby in this
case he had a nail so at least there's
that
at least there's that the left continues
to defend it continues to defend
Elizabeth Warren by the way I just this
new cycle this week is too much I'm not
sure I can handle what my brain is
exploding John Walsh the resident
feminist in chief over at the nation
which is to say a crazy person she has a
piece today called Donald Elizabeth
Warren will not let Donald Trump define
her because that's what she's doing when
she says she's Native American in fact
she won't even let biology define her
it's pretty amazing she won't let
anything she won't an objective reality
define her it's it's really really an
impressive feat according to John Walsh
Elizabeth Warren releasing her DNA test
was a way of preventing Donald Trump
from defining her so instead she defined
herself as a fool so that was great now
is it that that was that was really
exciting stuff
you remember Rachel Dolezal remember
there was that white lady who said she
was black so that she could be like the
head of the Spokane n-double-a-cp
and then people found out that she had
just been basically tanning her skin and
doing her hair out in in frizzy hair do
and everyone said well that's a white
lady and that's how racial hooked I
would bet money that if you took a
racial DNA test of of Rachel Dolezal she
has more African background that
Elizabeth Warren has a Native American
background and now I'm desperate to make
that happen so Rachel if you're
listening right now I will pay for your
23andme test because I want to know
whether you're more black than Elizabeth
Warren his Native American so that we
can laugh endlessly as the media which
ripped you to shreds has to has to say
that you are more black than Elizabeth
Warren his Native American I just think
that will be absolutely delicious okay
time for a couple of things that I like
and then a couple of things that I hate
so things I like today Lindsey Graham
2.0 is the best version of Lindsey
Graham he emerged during the Brett
Kavanaugh hearings he's sort of like
Demi vs boot Lovato
Lindsey Graham 2.0 is a better version
of Lindsey Graham 1.0 and his merge from
the basement aggressive
Sassie is all hell here is Lindsey
Graham going after senator Elizabeth
Warren and you just got to enjoy the
show man I'm gonna take a DNA test all
of you have I've been told and my
grandmother was part Cherokee and I mean
Indian it may all be just talk but
you're gonna find out in a couple of
weeks cuz I'm gonna take this you are
gonna take it I'm taking it and the
results gonna be revealed here this is
my Trump moment this is reality TV okay
well good stuff from Lindsey Graham's
who point out other things that I like
so Hillary Clinton was in a van not the
van that she collapsed into on 9/11 2016
a different man and shoes at an event
I guess raising money for Senator Bob
Menendez New Jersey because he suddenly
found himself in a bit of a firefight
for a Senate seat and the van crashed
here is what that looked like
[Music]
and there isn't there's Hillary like
well I hope she wasn't driving Hey
but that is I mean let's let's be honest
that is not the first time that Hillary
Clinton has been stopped by the polls so
that was uh oh I know you loved it come
on guys come on you love the punning
it's it's there hey Hillary Clinton that
that I have such a good joke that I
could say right now but I've pledged not
to make any more van driver jokes I
won't that is that is a that solid stuff
from from Hillary Clinton who just
consider the punchlines I don't know who
this week decided that they would go to
the punch line Asylum and let out all
the patients but all the punch lines are
running free and there's no way for me
to catch them all I only only one man
with one butterfly net I can't keep up
with the chaos there is no way for me to
catch every punch line that has now
escaped the asylum so stop it people put
the put the punch lines back where they
belong
Sallis don't get had time for a couple
of things that I hate so thing number
one I hate two GOP candidates have now
been assaulted in Minnesota according to
Bill McMorris over at the Washington
free beacon the Minnesota Democratic
Party has suspended a spokesman for
calling for violence against Republicans
even as two GOP candidates have been
assaulted and suspected politically
motivated attacks the
democratic-farmer-labor party has
suspended communications staffer William
Davis for a week because he said
Democrats should bring Republicans to
the guillotine and also to different
Republicans have now been assaulted
Minnesota State Representative Sarah
Anderson was punched in the arm after
spotting a man destroying Republican
yard signs
she said the attack left her scared and
her attacker all need assisted when she
fled to her car and threw it in reversed
and then there was another GOP candidate
who's also attacked his name is Shane
mecklen he suffered a concussion after
getting sucker-punched while speaking
with constituents at a restaurant in
Benton County he says that he has
suffered memory loss and doctors told
him you'll have a four to six week
recovery time ahead of him he said his
cold-cocked while sitting at a high-top
table at a local eatery and he hit his
head on the floor so well done mob
politics everything is going great hey
other things that I hate today there's a
story from the alcohol's France press
the AFP
saying that there is a new reality to
the in France and here is how it goes
it's a new dating show
helping time press Millennials save on
the unnecessary preliminaries by cutting
straight to the chase the show is called
making love and it has jaws dropping at
MIPCOM the world's biggest TV market in
con by having contestants have sex first
before deciding if they like each other
it's French producers we make says it
has brought together scientifically
matched singles to ask the essential
question could making love make you fall
in love the answer is no you idiots
we've been trying this in Western
societies for the last forty years since
the rise of the radical feminist
movement and sexual revolution it is a
giant fail having sex with people first
does not make them fall in love it makes
him an satisfied that he has had sex
first okay you this is so stupid I
cannot even tell you but I guess the
idea here is if we're up like animals
suddenly love will be the outcome if you
have that little love in your life that
you think that sex with a random
stranger is suddenly going to usher in
an era of nuptial bliss you're out of
your damn mind you're out of your mind
and ladies if you think that this is how
you're gonna hook a man is by having sex
with him you're crazy that's not what
hooks a man that really isn't any man
will have sex with any mildly attractive
woman at any time that's how men operate
if you think that you offering sex to a
guy is somehow going to get him to stick
that is just not true that is just not
true to get men to commit requires you
to actually not do that it requires you
to actually suggest to a man that
perhaps a relationship is necessary in
order for physical lovemaking to be part
of the process here that is why marriage
was built in the first place was a great
institution for women too bad radical
feminists decided to throw it all away
okay well we will be back here tomorrow
with all of the latest and craziest news
I don't know I can't even predict what's
gonna happen by tomorrow I just I've
ever run out of predictions so we'll
tell you then I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens edited by Alex and Garo Audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018